das gemeinsame telefon hier von
kanada auf todd's m'kenzie das parodie telefon yoko auf
classf auf um vídeo gotcha walk of the
earth beilage hose vasudevas armee ja
im gemeinschaftsvideo johannes lb wie lange
kennt ihr euch und wie oft
hattet ihr schon  um das Video aufzunehmen,
jemand, den ich früher kannte, wir kennen uns als mich Marshal, wir kennen uns seit
etwa 60 Jahren, etwa sechs Jahre, und ich kenne Sarah
seit etwa drei Jahren, und ich kenne
diese Typen seit etwa zwei Jahren, und wir im
Grunde  begannen wegen der
Musik abzuhängen und wir wurden Freunde und all dieser
Jazz und was das Video von jemandem, den ich
früher kannte, wir übten es ungefähr
zwei Tage lang und dann dauerte es ungefähr 30 Takes
am Tag von 30 Versuchen 30 Versuchen, ja, wir haben
es verstanden  am neunundzwanzigsten, verdammte Kate, 26.
Fisch, weil wir uns nicht erinnern,
neun, mit denen du sprichst, weißt du nicht, oh,
wirklich, 50 Versuche und wir haben es am
43. geschafft, ja, ich denke, es ist
ungefähr so herum  runden Sie ab, was
Sie von der Parität halten  von Key of
Awesome oh, wir lieben es, wir kennen
diese Jungs, wir haben mit ihnen gesprochen, und
wir werden eine Parodie mit ihnen machen, wenn
sie in ein paar Wochen und im April nach Toronto kommen,
aber ich denke, es ist urkomisch, ok,
es ist wirklich schön  fertig das ist eine
frage über die deutsche parodie von dir
aber du weißt es wahrscheinlich nicht oh ich weiß
wenn du redest ja ja deine
eigene klasse ja ja ja du weißt es ich
weiß es sie haben mich durch eine alte
frau ersetzt ja  Was ist das alles, sie
will vielleicht nicht hören, dass du mein Stolz
selbst bist, sie haben mich durch eine
schöne Frau ersetzt, los geht's, ich verstehe es nicht,
sagte Ser, du, Mama, ja, ich meine,
ja, das war eine gute gute
Parodie, die ich kann  ähm ja, es
gab tonnenweise tennyson von ihnen, nein nein, sie
sehen nur, wie viele Parodien über dich,
wenn du auf youtube bist, ich glaube, es gibt
zu viele, um sie zu zählen, es gibt sehr viele,
es gibt viele, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber die eine ist
die deutsche und  das amerikanische Wunder,
sie sind beide ziemlich lustig, hat es dir
gefallen, y  es würde mir sehr gefallen es ist
sehr lustig besonders deine Rolle ist sehr
ja er hat gute Arbeit geleistet Tony ich habe gute
Arbeit geleistet ja ich würde ihm gerne irgendwann ein Bier
ausgeben, also steht das auf meiner To-do-Liste
okay  was war was für eine idee oder wer hatte
die idee dass man nur auf der
rechten oder linken seite ist und fast nichts tut
ich habe mein ganzes leben vorbereitet ja da ist
der schnipser und der zupf ja und die
uhr ist sehr anspruchsvoll hab mir mein
herz ausgespielt  und wenn die Leute darauf anspielen
, dass ich gerade heruntergeladen habe, tut es wirklich
weh. Nicht mit dem Plick für den
Flick an der Flagge zupfen. Sagen, ich glaube, Sara hatte die
Idee, dass er der Medizinbart-
Typ sein soll, richtig, du hast einfach so cool ausgesehen
Er starrte nach rechts,
alles andere, was er tat, mochte
seine Coolness nicht, also dachte ich, ich starre
das ganze Video nur so und dann wurde er zum
Barttyp. Ich habe meine Marschbefehle
von ihr für die letzten zwei Monate erhalten
okay sie hat gekämpft okay das ist schwer
mm-hmm ja frauen sind benebelt warum dieses
lied ah naja mo  Hammer, ähm, es ist ein verdammt
gutes Lied, es ist nicht gerade das
beste Lied des Jahres oder der letzten
fünf Jahre, das ich gehört habe, also kann nichts schief gehen,
es ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut gemacht
Du hast
es zuerst gesagt,
ja, und Johnnys erstaunlicher
Sohn, wenn er nicht redete, könnte von
der Erde gehen, Wissen, genug getan haben,
Erbe, noch Tag an, dann
Diskretion, siehe Dagobah, riesiges Oh, boohoo,
für wen ETA einen Fordham-Grund für f4
Phantom II Saginaw bekommt  i nevah unda askia oh
das ist nicht, dass ich die analytische
Turbine kenne und weiter von Lake George alle
Sonogramme und sie haben meinen Witz
über Klassenfilm adelbert Frage
geredet opciones ein gefälschter Ausweis anam vas Adapter über
ihn sprechen über einen Johnson ist fertig